to an extent yes
yes yes
obviously it does the reason i say it
does is because
you can enjoy your young ages but don't
destroy it yeah like yeah you can have
fun and do whatever like
but if you just go and be loose and just
do everything like it's gonna be hard to
get like
um like in this day and age there's some
girls that have bc's that are older than
their age so it's like by the time they
get into that stage where they want to
like settle down because you've been
around it's like no one's going to take
you seriously yeah maybe one guy will be
very hard to get maybe one
ah there's always hope for everyone in
it but you know
maybe one guy like
whoa but it's like even if now like you
marry that girl imagine walking down the
road oh yeah like she slopped me off in
the block oh yeah she did
something
no but that's something you're gonna
have to live with like for the rest of
your life you get it yeah and
like even if you marry her yeah it's
like cool you have to go through all
this time to marry the girl it took me
what two weeks just to get slops you get
it so it's like
well it's kind of like she gave
something
to that guy for free and she's making
you like pay for it yeah yeah
i'm trying to see
if you've got to pick the right person
for you man
whatever you're ready to deal with
yeah i mean if two j bags meet then they
can be together in it but yeah because
they both know what they're on that's
crazy yeah you know i would say though i
would say you like what you like so
if there's a girl that you really like
but a past is crazy
that's not really gonna matter too tough
because
you liking the factors more than what
she's done with other people before i
think it depends on like what happens
between when you've started speaking to
her i mean yeah and then moving onwards
if if it's still wild then
you'll throw that away jesus christ
sorry guys
do you guys do you guys ask girls that
you're seeing like about what they've
done before or do you just you're like
see no either evil hear no evil like i
don't want to know really i think i
think when you're when you're going to
speak
someone knows something do you i mean so
you don't really even have to ask
directly
you can kind of get
a sense of who someone is
just about the way they speak and where
they talk and the way their friends
speak about them and stuff like that
yeah they don't really have
them directly to kind of gauge what's
going on more time they can lie as well
yeah they can actually live maybe not
would you know if they're lying
you never know exactly if i tell you
three like you can't argue with me like
a lot of girls know every single person
a lot of girls who say that pc is one
it's really 20.
[Music]
because they know that because they know
but that's actually some girls some
girls would like saying that their bc is
one and if you're oh that's calm you get
to know her and then
she's getting it
all the tricks out of the bag that's
right i'm not
he told you that and then that's when
that's when that problem is going to
start in it because like they know that
the type of guy you are you're not going
to deal with a girl that's like out
there so they're going to have to lie to
you but that's something you never know
mm-hmm so
she yeah you should be open from the
start but i guess you can't avoid in
certain situations
but okay so bc is one thing right
like like so girl what's what she's done
but i think it takes it to another level
when it's on the internet like i have
brothers i would never tell them to deal
with a girl that has any sort of only
fans any sort of sex tape on the
internet like ever
because like your kids are going to see
that one day
and like that's what you're seeing now
with kim kardashian like look at the
like she has to have that conversation
with all four of her kids so can you
imagine having a mom with an off like an
only fans
[Music]
that's a really that's a really specific
like
how do you know the truth
no but like
[Laughter]
[Music]
no but if we're talking about like kim k
of course like
her sex tape is going to be out there
because she's really up there but if
we're talking back about like a normal
person mm-hmm i think it's gonna go away
you're not gonna like find a video like
of someone that you don't really know
about
i think things definitely like brush
over like think think about coming along
i think about school that time stuff
gets sent around that's like now do you
even remember that no look look at ash
cash bro now
because of what she done exactly but
like not everyone's gonna be popping
like that's right
you're gonna be popping like that i mean
right
[Music]
now if she's if she's
no no no no
[Music]
i think there's i think there's
exceptions to every rule right but it's
still like in general
like i just don't know why as a guy
you'd want to deal with that do you
think that guys put up with like bad
behavior because a chick is like really
good looking some people do yeah i think
it's more easier to look over yeah you
know like let's say like you bagged
let's say you back
let's see you've had one lengthening now
and it's like the girl is toxic but
because she's lengthy you know like if
you have her by her side i'm animal like
yeah i rate your thing so when you go
behind closed doors she might be so
toxic like bro like no one's meant to be
going through that but because she's
laying like she that's what you're like
you're putting up with it because you
just want to keep her there you get it
so yeah
i think a lot of guys care about like
other like guys validating them that's
why they put up with it but and that's
how we'll stem from but even now like
girls of bad behavior like all that
toxic [ __ ] like it's normalized now so
a lot of guys tend to look for that now
it's just crazy
yeah some guys like it man
i have been saying that every show that
i think there's a type of guy that likes
girls that are a little bit mean to them
yeah they're all mean and keep them keen
like no but i don't
like dad next question
no like no it will i just like will
smith okay take will smith no no let's
just use him as an example okay
you cannot you can
you can't you cannot tell me that will
smith did not have the option to pick a
girl that was nice to him when he was on
the fresh prince of freaking bel-air
he could have had his pick of what like
lined up
and he picked the one girl
that like is borderline and like abusive
to
she was in love him
tupac yeah she was in love with someone
else
at the beginning because like what
you're shown like what someone decides
to show you could be completely
different than what they really are do i
mean it's like years down the line it
could be tomorrow but it could be years
down she was like crying on their
wedding day what do you mean
how long they would have been for and
obviously their signs and stuff but like
yeah if you like it you like it
yeah
now will smith went up on the stage i
actually smacked some of her and she
said that she still did all that with a
madness like that's crazy i could never
have a goal that like i'll do that for
my man just listen no yes mama made a
joke about your your your head
no no no no
i'm not trying to violently mama made a
joke about your head
no no but no but keep it cool that's one
thing another guy went into your wife
you could even tuck him down to do
nothing like i can't let your waist man
no no viola i'll be so real will smith i
love fresh version of bella bro like
that's my guy but after i saw that and i
saw everything
there's levels to that you're not gonna
go for the guy bro what are you gonna go
for the guy first her bro but that's
what i'm saying if you're not gonna go
for the guy that went into your wife
don't go for no one that chats about
your wife bro yeah i think